[Music]
i've examined this foregoing book
meaning the first book having been
commanded to look carefully through it
and to verify the information i find in
it about the affairs of the sea and
about its kings and their various
circumstances and to compare this
information with other reports passed
down about these kings
known to myself but not appearing in the
book i found the date of the book to be
about the year 237
a time when maritime businesses still
ran on an even keel on account of all
the towing and throwing overseas
by merchants from iraq i also found that
everything recounted in the first book
follows a truthful and voracious line
[Music]
the indians and chinese are all of the
opinion that of the world's kings
four are to be counted as great they
consider the first of these four to be
the king
of the arabs it is a unanimous opinion
among them
about which there is no disagreement but
of the four kings he is the mightiest
the richest in possessions
and the most resplendently fine in
appearance and that he is the king
of the great religion to which nothing
is superior
the king of china counts himself next in
importance after the king of the arabs
then comes the bison team king and
finally balhara
king of the indians who pierce their
ears
this video is sponsored by skillshare
the online learning platform
skillshare has been very useful for me
and my brother over history time on our
youtube journey
not just for more technical classes like
this excellent one from dan dan leo and
documentary film
but also for simple life hacks like this
productivity class from thomas frank
simple tips that have been able to turn
this lock down on its head for my
brother and me
and have helped us make time to create a
whole third youtube channel in the gaps
we freed up
and that's skillshare whether you're a
professional or just starting out it's a
great resource for self-improvement
with thousands of classes fit for any
schedule and to start you off the first
thousand of my subscribers to click the
link in the description
we'll get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
and make the most of 2021
[Music]
in every kingdom in india the ruling
family belonged to a single dynasty
from which the royal title never passes
to another house
they appoint crown princes the case is
similar with scribes and physicians they
all
belong to distinct family lines to which
the particular occupation is
restricted the various kings in india do
not
owe allegiance to a single ruler instead
each as master of his own country
however is regarded as india's king of
kings
in contrast to the indians the chinese
do not appoint crown princes
i do not know of a single member of
india who is a muslim
and arabic is not spoken the indians
possess few horses that they are more
common in china the chinese however do
not possess elephants and do not let
them remain in their land as they regard
them ill omened
the king of india has many troops but
they are not paid as regular soldiers
instead he summons them to fight for
king and country and they go to war at
their own expense
and at no cost at all to the king in
contrast the chinese
give their troops regular pay as the
arabs do
there are some in india whose habit is
to wander the jungles and hills
seldom mixing with other people
sometimes they live on leaves and jungle
fruits and
insert iron rings into the heads of
their penises to stop them from having
sexual intercourse with women
there are some among them who are naked
and others who stand upright
all day facing the sun naked too but for
a
scrap of tiger or leopard skin i once
saw
one of these men just as i have
described i went away
and did not return until 16 years later
and there i saw him
still in the same position i was amazed
at how his eyes had not melted from the
heat of the sun
the indians wear two waist cloths and
adorn themselves with bangles of gold
and jewels the men as well as the women
indian men can marry as many women as
they like
the stable food of the indians is rice
they do not
eat wheat the indians let their beards
grow long and i have often seen an
indian with a beard
three cubits in length also they don't
clip their moustaches
neither the indians nor the chinese
bathe themselves
when in a state of ritual pollution the
indians however bathe daily before
eating their morning meal
the indians do not have sexual
intercourse with their women when they
are menstruating
indeed they find them so offensive that
they turn them out of the house
india is greater in extent than china
several
times so and has a greater number of
kings
china though is more densely inhabited
and cultivated
the chinese have no native tradition of
religious learning
in fact their religion came from india
they maintain it was the indians who
introduced the idols
to their land and that they the indians
were the original people
of religion in both lands they believe
in the transmigration of souls as a
basic tenet although they differ
on the resulting details of dogma
in most of the land of india there are
no urban settlements
but everywhere you go in china they have
a great walled city
also china is a healthier country with
fewer diseases
and better air in both countries there
are big rivers
some of them bigger than our rivers and
both have plentiful rain
india however has many desert areas
while all of china is populated and
cultivated
indians regard entertainment as shameful
and never
indulgent they don't drink intoxicating
drink
either nor do they consume vinegar
because it is produced from such
drink this is a case not a religious
belief but of disapproval
they say a king who drinks is not a king
at all
the reason being that in most indian
states they are surrounded by
neighboring kings who make war on them
so they say
how can someone run a kingdom properly
if he is drunk
sometimes kings fight each other for the
control of a state but this happens
infrequently
i've never seen anyone actually take
another king's country by force
except in the case of a people
neighboring the land of pepper
and if a king does conquer another
kingdom he appoints some member of the
defeated king's family to rule it as his
puppet because the people of the kingdom
will tolerate no
other arrangement when a king of the
land of sarandebe dies
his course is paraded on a low bedded
cart lying on its back with its head
dangling off the rear of the cart
so that the hair drags up dust from the
ground
and all the while a woman with a broom
sweeps more dust onto the corpse's head
and cries out
oh you people behold your king only
yesterday he reigned over you
and you obeyed his every word see now
what has come
and the manner of this going from the
world for the angel of death has taken
his soul
henceforth let life delude you never
more
then a pyre of sandalwood camphor and
saffron is made ready
and the corpse is burnt on it and the
ashes scattered to the wind
all the indians burn their dead on pyres
sarendib the last of the islands is part
of the land
of india at times it happens that when a
dead king is burnt
his women folk enter the fire too and
are burned alive along with him but if
they wish they do not do so
in the case of the indians if a thief
steals
as little as a fields or upwards a long
stake is brought
the end is sharpened and then that thief
is impaled on it
backside first until the point comes out
of his gut it
in india if a man accuses another of an
offense for which the mandatory penalty
is death
the accuser is asked will you subject
the person you have accused
to ordeal by fire if he agrees to this a
piece of iron
is first heated to such a high
temperature that it becomes red hot
the accused man is told to hold out his
hand palm up
and on it are placed seven leaves from a
particular tree of theirs
the red hot iron is then placed on his
hand on top of it
the leaves next the accused has to walk
up and down holding the iron until he
can bear it no longer and has to drop it
at this point a leather bag is brought
out the man has to put his hand inside
this
then the bag is sealed with the ruler's
seal when three days have passed
some unhusked rice is brought and the
accused man is told to husk it by
rubbing it between his palms
if after this no mark is found on his
hand he is deemed to have got the better
of the accuser
and he escapes execution i have seen a
man put his hand in
and bring it out unharmed in such a case
too his accuser is fined
and mourned of gold
in dharma's land the marked bushan or
rhinoceros is to be found
this animal has a single horn on the
front of its forehead
and within this horn is a marking a
naturally occurring figure
depicting the likeness of a human being
or some other form
the horn is black throughout except for
this white figure
in its interior this rhinoceros is by
nature smaller than the elephant
but tends to be the same dark color as
the elephant
an elephant will run away in fear from a
rhinoceros
the rhinoceros is a ruminant like cattle
and camels
and its flesh is permissible for muslims
we have eaten it
the chinese use them to make belts
[Music]
all the kings of india and china believe
in the transmigration of souls
and hold it as an article of faith a
trustworthy informant reported that one
of their
kings in these lands was afflicted by
smallpox
when he had recovered he looked in the
mirror and thought how hideous his face
had become
seeing one of his brother's sons he said
to him it is not for the like of me to
dwell in this body
now it is so changed the body is after
all a mere
receptacle for the soul when the soul
passes out of it
it returns in another receptacle you
must be king in my place for i shall now
destroy my soul from my body
until such time as i alight in another
body
he then called for a dagger of his that
had a particularly sharp edge
and commanded that his head be severed
with it he was duly decapitated
then his corpse was burnt
certain kings of theirs when they ascend
the throne have rice cooked for them
and placed for them on banana leaves the
new king invites three or four hundred
of his companions
they come of their own free choice not
under any compulsion from the king and
gives them some of the rice having first
eaten some himself
one by one they come up to him take a
little of the rice and eat it
it then becomes obligatory for all those
who have eaten some of the rice
when the king dies or is killed to burn
themselves to death
by fire
[Music]
concerning the yasara that occurs in
india meaning the monsoon rain
it falls on the land continuously
throughout the summer for three
consecutive months night and day
the rainfall never letting up at all
they lay in their basic provisions in
advance of it and when the yasara comes
they stay put in their houses
because they are solidly built of wood
no one ventures out
except for some pressing need craftsmen
however fly their trades in these places
throughout the period of the reigns
[Music]
among the indians there are religious
devotees and men of learning known as
brahmans
as well as poets who frequent the courts
of kings astrologers philosophers
soothsayers and
those who take auguries from the flights
of crows and other birds
in india there are a group of people
known as the bikajis
they are naked although their hair is so
long that it covers their upper bodies
they let their fingernails grow as long
as spearheads for they are never clipped
or only if they get broken and they live
a life of wandering
[Music]
i have avoided relating any of the sorts
of accounts in which sailors exercise
their powers of invention
but whose credibility would not stand up
to scrutiny in other men's minds
i've also restricted myself to relating
only the true contents of each account
and the shorter the better and god it is
who guides us to what is correct
and praise be to god lord of the
universe and may his blessings be upon
the choicest part of his creation
muhammad and on all his family
you